guys i want to start this
by saying
buffalo come see me
buffalo this daddy has amazing tickets
we got to move some tickets push i know
it's go see brian buffalo
very funny he's giving out free chicken
wings and blue drops
and jim jim kelly and steve tasker are
opening up for them they're opening in
buffalo and buffalo so yeah and we're
your brendan shaw buffalo bills jerseys
there's four of them out there there's
four of them out there they did sell
them for quite some time and i'll be i
need my royalties yeah tomorrow tomorrow
thursday friday saturday not a big deal
he's got a he's got a t-shirt cannon
yeah so like now if i do
tickets bruce smith is going to be there
yeah and if i don't sell a lot of
tickets and you know this your kids
don't eat it's the only time i get very
depressed
there's no talking to me there's no
talking to me i sit in the i sit like
this on my phone and i don't want
anything to drink i don't want to talk
to anybody i'm a nightmare to be around
i just go it's just it's
shut up when you do a club and you don't
sell tickets it's like you can call and
complain your agent can come complain
like dude this i won't say the name of
the comic book he's just torn to me
about not selling tickets i'm like did
it make sense it's on him you're your
own yeah marketing and then don't think
i don't hate it it's it's literally it's
literally yourself it's it's literally
the fan saying we don't want to see it
oh i called him up i called him up
during live this past year during cove
stuff and i called him up and i go i go
i gave him i had no one else to call i
call him i go hey these are my [ __ ]
ticket counts i go [ __ ] i want
to kill everybody i want to kill so and
he goes like this he goes look i know
there's nothing i can say right now to
make you feel better i know you're
really pissed off and and you were like
you gave me some things yeah i was like
yeah i gotta [ __ ] go get guys
i get
murderous yeah and there's no talking to
me because it's definitely personal it's
perfect it's the people of buffalo or
san jose where we're at saying we're
good
i've only been doing this my whole life
it's only been i've only tried my very
best and sometimes my very best ain't
good enough hey and i'm not good at
marketing maybe and maybe i should get
better and maybe i should get better at
all my other stuff but you know
sometimes i just don't feel funny either
so days i just feel [ __ ] and by the
way you're on one today i know right now
i'm going brian some tickets got to sell
some tickets dude i guess some yeah are
you staying at the hotel they're gonna
put you in the haunted one no i'm gonna
i'm gonna stay at the i'm gonna stay in
another hotel your brother gave me a
hotel okay stay at the haunted one oh
and they have an open there who say
monster really monster i'm bringing dove
david off but maybe
but half of him that guy i'm seeing yeah
he has the hottest 20 you ever see ask
me 21 not his thing
20. that's it don't say hey can you do
22 tonight because he can't okay so the
20 is
what's his name is his name forget his
name all right not bad i am with dave
yep he'll probably reach out i'm the
worst with names and i'll tell you where
i'm really about you me or i'll meet my
oh yeah oh yeah well he didn't know my
wife's name for two years
i mean when i say when i say for two
years how's the house part of yourself
he had to pick something up from my
house cameron he shows up at my house me
and my girl watching me and my wife at
the time were watching tv and i'm in my
like i'm in like kind of sweats and
maybe something well this one you were
off montana and yeah and and she was in
like a little nightgown or something and
we're just watching tv all you know
cuddle up eating like you know kettle
corn or whatever you know and then
brennan adorable rings and brandon's
standing there we both answered the
phone the door we're like yeah i don't
know why you both came to the door hi
and and you go like this you go hi we go
and then you go
you know i could kill you both right now
i got what felt like you're serious i
can kill you i could take both of your
heads and go like this and you would
both die and your girl was like uh oh
how's i oh i was like it's kind of true
i went well see you later
dude that was eight years ago that was
eight years ago when you're off montana
[ __ ] that's why we first started like
podcasts we were driving a prius yep and
and yeah
he had to go change train and it was
costing too much money with gas orange
county so he would squeeze into this
little [ __ ] prius i kick it every time i
get out of the car
every
and i would park it illegally anywhere i
want yeah they just wouldn't give me
tickets
it was before everyone had a break cops
would pull me over for real and i'd go
and i would literally yeah i'm gonna
agree
i go listen to me right now you call
toyota you give them the ticket and i'm
gonna tell you what i had i had this
thing on sport and not eco and she opens
up like a [ __ ]
and they're dying
i go and i was going to give chase for
you guys because i would blow you away
if i want
oh
you try that whiskey
i'm going to try it right now
did you dry cow how's your [ __ ] i i
brought my i brought my favorite i'm
gonna say it's better i'm gonna stay
positive yeah so i'm excited i'm saying
it gets better dude i brought my all
this alcohol is making me a favorite
all the way from montana it's all i
drink when i go oh that is smooth
whistling andy is my absolute favorite
get it away montana local whiskey i
don't you can't get in stores i don't
think you get online i was gonna say
that that's my shop absolutely
nice yeah damn man it's my fave
oh montana does it right it's got it
it's got a it's got a
smooth flavor daddy yeah we're talking
about it anyways uh i found my favorite
fighter
from the ufc let's get uh let brian
guess because i know who it is come on
you guys currently fighting currently
fighting and i'm assuming he's black
francis again
come on dude oh it might be um
the guy who talks a lot tall no no was
that kevin hall
yeah i love the guy no no no no not that
guy
you're right
no no who's the guy that talks [ __ ]
kevin holland yeah
he's asking he's asking uh um literally
not him
keep going okay um
cheating well it should be izzy if it's
black it should be easy no keep going
not that famous not that
not ranked in the top 15.
has an amazing story about the ultimate
fighter yeah i'll tell you story in a
second yeah maybe background yeah
because i know who it is
khalil roundtree khalil roundtree and
i'll tell you why he won't
used to be 300 pounds you speak 300
pounds
really he worked out the uh
go to a fight shop he worked at the otn
fight shop he was 200 pounds decided to
get in shape and start fighting
and he came in the black house
and it was me there he was holy [ __ ]
anderson silva
and uh he jumps in the ring to spar with
me and ashton silva oh boy and i watch
him go they understand like
oh he did really well he did really well
and then he goes with me
and does really well and actually goes
he's in looks and views he's very good
hey this is why i go to that top he was
in the ufc at the time that video right
there he's not in the ufc no he just he
just look at him
bro he's a hardcore dude
should we get him on the show for you
dude that would be amazing wow yeah hold
on so so and he fights at 85 right now
or 85 yeah okay so who who's also in
that division i don't know the division
is he's in that division
okay so let me ask you so look by the
way
obviously looks like a real athlete
they're very strong so you just were
like you did he did really well so he
understood
had he had he been a boxer before this
kickboxing okay stud so he had a lot of
experience
wow
wow i don't think he's in the not the
top 15. oh he's not dude clover you'll
get up here though yeah
one uh he's fighting for the title dude
wow
at 40 years old dude
dude and you know you know who's waiting
in the in the shadows as the fill in if
somebody gets hurt hold on i know yuri
oh really
now i'm gonna be your next champion
there's a rumor luke rockhold is coming
back to fight yeah luke rockhold's
fighting strictly yeah that's a tough
fight for luke yeah
but luke's talented man yeah i mean we
know
luke's a monster i don't know why he
doesn't use he's a monster grabbler
monster grappler so homie was legit 300
pounds yeah damn that's [ __ ] insane
not like a chin so now when you were
like wait so when when he got in the
ring that's right that's when you were
sparring no no no no no
tall guy how do you think 300 pounds he
had [ __ ] me now he's walking
at 300 pounds he's walking around 220
right there no god no no uh his tall guy
no
maybe give him six foot
he's just what though people always
exaggerate their height you still find
that light heavy weight
i'm pretty sure he's uh he's he's not
still out light heavy is he still light
heavyweight oh he's from he's from l.a
yeah 31 years old that's my guy right
there nickname the war horse
all right
what would my nickname the nicest guy in
the world really yes i got now i got to
meet him i saw i saw him jamming into my
terror i was like i gotta i gotta meet
cut into him a rainbow comes out
yeah he's a stud man he fell on some
hard times you know yeah
he was gonna retire
mayor would do johnny walker too that's
the
who's calling the uh vitor bell for it
yeah it's a current event too bumpy
trump and his son can he get any cooler
trump in his son just when trump can't
get any cooler so
how how hilarious is he oh that reminds
me dude shane gillis dropped a special
on youtube
shane
youtube and it is absolutely [ __ ]
fire i bet he's a liar really fire and
there's no way uh i text him last night
about it there's no way that he could
have put it like netflix when it cleared
the subjects he's talking about
like off the bat i'm like oh this is my
time
is it an hour how long how long is it
447 minutes 47 but
there's no way that would have got
cleared by it thank you for telling me a
shame there's no way you would have got
to pop up buddy wow yeah right there one
day at 220 yeah you knew well over a
million oh that's well over a million
dude he gives shane gillis two million
dude oh he'll get two three million dude
when uh he talks about trump he's like
he's like how hilarious he goes whatever
you want to say you know how hilarious
was he during the uh debates
i don't wanna give away a joke but he's
talking about when uh uh what's saying
rand paul
uh it says something and you know
they're doing the uh debates and rand
paul's like you know i think should
focus on education everyone's all
and then uh uh ted cruz goes i think we
should focus on health care and then
what's up
and they get to trump and goes ted's
crew ted cruz wife is a dog a dog
everyone's like he can do that
yeah and then rand paul's like hey
they're like shut the [ __ ] up [ __ ] ugly
[ __ ]
he's he's just it's so good yeah he's
he's over there he's like i got jeb bush
low energy jeff he's like and jeb bush
goes you can't insult your way to the
white house that's again that's exactly
what he [ __ ] did low energy jeb uh
talked about how he's like dude these
these are lifelong politicians for 30 40
years trump's ever been in a debate he
said he'd show up to the debates like
what are we talking about
he goes like this he goes you can ask
anybody else a question it's getting
embarrassing it's all about me like i
was like how do you compete with that
dude no one does a better trump in like
when he impersonates them
yeah i can't teach the crowd how to do
it really yeah dude it's so cool
dude it's awesome
yeah i can't wait i've seen it i've seen
him do his hour quite a few times it's
just mad dragon is coming amazing yeah
gillis is up yeah
shane goes
because you know what buffalo loves more
than comedy football [ __ ] oh when you
get on stage go let's take the bills to
austin and see what they do
do that open without you by the way how
weird open with that i know let's take
the bills to austin and then you
i guess if you're a player you'd rather
plan austin excuse me
yeah i mean
no notice they can't well they have josh
allen who's an absolute monster but yeah
notice how you can't really get like
free agents to go there oh my god hey go
to go to orchard park uh it's gonna be
snowy 99
and it's so cold but the fans are great
the fans are great but like the best
family they play outside yeah oh yeah
yeah there's no
[Music]
when i watch guys like that with no
sleeves so when you played football you
played denver you played [ __ ] i never
wore sleeves because it's slippery on
the football how
on the way
so
so
i've always been fascinated i'm uh the
cat the cold makes me a coward i can
handle the heat yeah i can handle the
sports arm for you yeah no the cold
makes me a coward especially if i'm cold
and i got a helmet on oh a helmet and
it's all like the helmets so when you
when you
are out there what's the call that
you've ever played and do you think oh
man i mean i mean growing up playing pee
wee because it's zero degrees but
remember even at p in pee wee we're
playing
i mean mounds of snow do so you just we
planted reasons why you just get used to
it yeah so
but when you are playing say you're
gonna you got to go
let's go
when you gotta when you gotta what are
you saying you have to drive the wedge
yeah
okay when you gotta break the wedge and
it's really cold out like is your
adrenaline kicked in so you're just not
really feeling it or you aren't just
what you do it's like it's just your job
yeah it's you're gonna freak you don't
like if you're a coach like it's a
little cold for me do you mind if i take
this game off you like what you're fired
you're fine you're fired so you just
you just suck it up do you think you do
better in the cold than most people yeah
i don't mind it okay you don't mind it
so many football players like some like
dude aaron rodgers or like josh allen
are monsters in the cold dude remember
like tom brady they don't give up the
wide receiver played for for green bay
he was black dude rocked out of his mind
and i remember it was so [ __ ] cold
and he's wearing just sleeves and it was
yeah i feel the ball oh
he tripping and he was just so he was
and he was doing those guys
hard [ __ ] like a hard dude man
no like you just look at him and you go
you're made of different material like
is it we're in san jose this thursday
friday it's like
is it chilly chilly at night
yeah jim will you check the weather in
san jose is it 50s i mean chilly to me
because yeah montana at night and
mornings was cold yeah but san jose is
going to be hot as [ __ ] right is it oh
yeah dude
are they what are they doing with the
fires up there it's the very top one you
can see it oh san jose i'm sorry you
want to sound good
yeah okay well this morning oh you're
fine you're fine oh no it gets chilly at
night it gets chilly at night what is it
what does it say
at night that's not bad was it
not light jacket weather 57 69 87 81 81
it'll get cold 56 degrees that's still
not jacket weather no uh yeah like a
like a long sleeve yeah
i'll rock a long sleeve yeah oh a long
sleeve shirt yeah i won't wear like a
jacket
no justin can be in his [ __ ] gucci
[ __ ] i know right
you give him any excuse to wear it just
[ __ ] in the pockets yeah my buddy
tell me who's this navy seal um told me
that he
he almost died he felt like he was going
to die he thought he was going to die
the coldest he was ever at was when they
were they were in the south china sea
and i guess
they these seals they have these like
they're almost like these submarines
that are open
they're open they they're a cage over it
yeah you go under and you have scuba
gear on oh yeah so you go under and then
you then you come up and you wait till
the tide so the tide comes in
but it's the south china sea
you wet you got a wetsuit but you wet
and so what happens is your body
temperature will start to acclimate with
the water so they're sitting there
waiting for the tide and there's nothing
they can do you have to wait until the
tide comes in and you just deal with it
and it's got to be secret you know
and you're in like off near the coast of
korea or something yeah
and it gets
and he said i i thought at that point i
was going to die like i wasn't going to
be able to make it and you're sitting
there wet for it
hours it's like people think hours yeah
yeah and i asked him that because we
were i'm such a [ __ ] we were eating in
venice yeah at a restaurant no no and
at a restaurant outside and i had i had
uh my my undershirt yeah a long sleeve
shirt and a sweater and i was i was
chilly i was like
and he had a t-shirt tie t-shirt on a
v-neck t-shirt on and that's all he had
and he was just talking and for an hour
and
for two hours he just it didn't even
dawn
how are you
yeah so i think some people are able to
conserve heat better i can't [ __ ] with
it some people are just tougher than
others you know well i think that's what
this sounds like no i'll tell you why
because i think if i had to fight in the
desert i might be just fine with
everybody
or winner buddy no no desert i'm good
why do you say that because i don't get
hot and i always like these people are
dying oh really because 110 degree
weather you don't get hot
you complain like crazy
i'm not saying i'm not a complainer sir
yeah
you're just saying you can handle it i
feel like if the seals had to fight from
just the dead i'm better for desert
warfare the desert storm you're using
trip
i mean right how hot does it gets cold
at night in the day oh that's right it's
cold
maybe it's not for me in general
i like how you tried though you tried
you guys could the difference is if we
all have to go join the military you
guys can carry all the weight
i got to carry the same amount of weight
my body everyone cares the same way it
takes 80 pounds that's a lot away from
me oh everyone came here
you guys you're all no matter what size
you are you guys are all good for me
it's a problem
how about we show up to zoo this morning
i
park and i look in the car and mark's
laying there like this oh yeah
what's wrong with me he was i don't feel
good bro i'm like oh no
like what do you feel like he's like all
i hear is like chinese in my head
that's weird and i went no that's cool
he's getting tested today but yeah like
he got in the car and he was just like
all i hear my inner thoughts is chinese
what do you think
he's so
i can't get over i was watching bradley
martin bench press
young ladies like just you have the belt
on benching like that
i was like
like crazy then he did this [ __ ] he was
doing one arm
snatches with a human being with a girl
on his i mean
that's weird you should work out with
him
no i mean that's a different thing
that's a different thing that's i mean i
mean well he's just so amazed by him i'm
like why don't you work out with him
well he's he's stronger is that the
strongest guy you've met ever seen
excuse me
i don't know that he seems strongly nfls
players well he's that strong isn't he
no he could keep up oh yeah that's a
strong man
he's dead lifting 750. sure sure he's
probably the strongest person i've ever
seen he's rapping with 600. sure uh
there's guys
who is a polynesian on the university of
colorado football why are you talking to
him now he did all the weight in the
world
we didn't have enough weights for that
well certain now you're talking about
simone you didn't have enough weights
what was it what did you squat like 800
for reps like okay that's cool oh it's
moana squatting
goddamn dude so bradley's strong yes but
they're the nfl like aaron donald
you ever seen aaron donald no oh of
course bring up aaron donald now don't
even write valley martin is very strong
but can some of those nfl guys like
their bench and deads are stupid
really and they make all the money in
the world sir because that's what they
do for a job oh no he's yeah he's strong
huh well he well hold on he's 290 pounds
okay and he looks like that okay and he
can lift all the weight name await he'll
do it
is that right yep
gosh
yeah
and and the guy next to him is big but
oh and he might be the best defensive
tackle
ever is that right two-time defense
player he's 290 looking like that how
tall is he
six two maybe six one came from
university of pittsburgh good luck
that's the fastest first step of all
time what [ __ ] what they they the nfl
the players rate the top players you
know like the players rank who's the
number one player yeah and he's number
one every year what so he's unstoppable
and what's he he just moves crazy wait
well that's a freak that's a freak it's
a total freak he's a total freak
i mean you know okay
who's the other guy you named
uh
well anytime you say a samoan name i'm
like it's like the guy there's just
there's there's freaks he's 343 pounds
he goes yeah i weighed myself today i
got i'm 343. because he didn't have any
fat on him and he was six feet tall and
i shook his hand and my hand didn't go
around his hand i went
it's like rich incognito another one
when i met him i was like he's stupid
but bradley doesn't weigh as much those
guys either like pound for pound
bradley's right up there bradley's 260
and he's stupid he's 260 yeah he's
stupid strong yeah he's really but also
he can jump he's he's one of those guys
probably he's been working out all his
life physically i think i feel like yeah
i love doing this gotta calm down i like
to do that to you do you know who jj
watt is yeah yeah yeah
yeah 300 pounds yeah yeah 40 inch
vertical nice you got to calm down
because there's some real athletes out
there who make millions of dollars
very i would say very athletic no i
understand i think bradley martin if he
had grown up playing football oh he'd
been the nfl
i think that kind of strengthened
intensity oh sure there's a chance he
could have been in the nfl no now here's
the other thing i want to talk to you
about take it easy here's the other take
okay
so if there's a drug test
aaron donald's gonna pass that drug test
ah because he was naturally born like
that right now hold on
jj what multiple-time nfl player of the
year and his his brother
and his uh younger brother all in the
nfl and his young brother those guys
should have won nfl different player of
the year last year for the pittsburgh
steelers but got [ __ ]
also will pass a drug test okay i feel
like you're saying at zoo culture there
are
not everybody's completely natural
we don't know
either way well
it's like saying phil heath should be in
the nfl
yeah because he lives in a lot of ways
you're stupid
i just feel like hey hold on
you're [ __ ] stupid
hold on no no you know what i'm saying
no hold on hey hold on what stupid no
okay hold on no i don't mean like but be
careful now i don't mean in life okay
when it comes to sports
anything like
nfl laying around no no no any any sport
that requires a locker room yeah yeah
you're stupid okay
i feel like i feel bad i was
any sport that requires you to
yeah here i'm gonna hang my stuff here
yeah that's happening it's stupid
no bradley's a monster though there's no
doubt about it my favorite thing to do
to brennan is to do that to him when a
guy's never played sports i go i could
have played in the nfl and he goes like
this he goes what did you say
because there's so many factors this
week yeah because i'm like i'm like
remember i said a weird thing like that
the guy was able to pop my head and then
i felt like oh [ __ ] and then close the
door yeah very best and played since you
were a kid sir since i was seven that's
the best guy since i was seven i played
tackle football and we're way to go dad
yep and we're friends with people like
klopp who got terrible injuries and you
watched people who were amazing who
couldn't make it because of five
different factors that were out of your
clothes the best players in the world
and all just didn't make it yeah and so
when you say
that guy could be an nfl
d1 football was going to play in the nfl
you just say that to him and he goes
what'd you say
what'd you say
what was like your buddy was him herman
the comic yeah we he came to our show at
high actually played a great dude
so when you're like dude he should be in
the middle
yeah yeah
yeah
okay have you ever seen the mbdl have
you seen the guys there
yeah i don't know it's it's when you get
into it and you why do you think you say
it
i love doing it it's like this or you
because i feel like sometimes you do
really believe me no no he doesn't come
up here
here's why
actually i know because i because i
would say good i want to fight in ufc
yeah
the problem is that when you go to
compete in anything but especially
football yeah tennis i like watching
tennis so when somebody's 56th in the
world do you know how good they are do
you know how hard that is for golf
oh my god
yeah the 100th ranked dude in golf yeah
is so unbelievably [ __ ] good at golf
unbelievable you're just like dude
hundred he sucks like no [ __ ] because
you're used to watching tiger woods and
phil mickelson who are
once-in-a-generation talent yeah you
know [ __ ] good that guy this guy was
56 playing the number five a 17 seed or
16 seed yeah and he was like the guy
that guy's good i go
did you say he's good he's the 56th best
he's ranked which means if you walked
into a room and saw all the tennis
players in the world that wanted to play
if you walk in you walk into uh you
could say you walk into any college and
you see all those d1 football players
everybody's competing
everybody's such an athlete they were
all all stars in in high school yeah i
looked at because as a wrestler in high
school i looked at what the wrestling
pedigree of some of the guys in bellator
were like the guy who never lost at
notre dame who who wrestled all four
years and never lost in high school
those guys and then and he's still
ranked number
seven
and you watch the level of competition
so when you watch and people say well
you know he was this wrestler he was
that wrestler or whatever
it's so [ __ ] difficult you can be
amazing and you're an alternate on the
olympic team and you never actually
wrestle in the olympics no that that
makes a lot of sense because i've had
people go oh you you could have been
good at football i go no i couldn't yeah
but you don't there's there's just no
[ __ ] there's so many other factors
and yeah injury uh are you willing to
wake up at 5 30. are you on your best
day when it came out exactly who saw you
that day did the scouts see there's so
many
people just going off my sides and i'm
like there's no way in [ __ ] hell
because i've tried it yeah i was like oh
i don't like this at all like just the
whole [ __ ] try
unless you've done it yeah unless you've
done it well it's like when i got my
starbucks this morning the guy you know
he's a big ufc fan he goes dude till
needs to [ __ ] quit am i right
no dude no he's i think they have him at
eight i go dude hold on hold on you're
saying these are quick because you've
seen him fight the absolute best guys
yeah he went to decision with robert
whitaker they just need to ease up maybe
he's just not at that level yet but i go
dude top eight in the world if take uh
the people that fight or even walk
around 170 pounds he's top eight in the
world star
and i said and he should do what what
should he do instead what should he do
instead are you out of your mind dude
it's just a rough patch but that's the
common fail like oh he's done no dude
come on i can't stand that i've always
hated that one people but usually mma is
not i mean if you lose four out of five
i get that but also
like
he went for a while he went like he got
knocked out by um
she never lost four out of five got
gusting knocked him out um he got [ __ ]
up by uh okay uh
oh no i'm sorry uh was it jones don
jones it was also who was the guy who
knocked his tooth sky high
francis anthony johnson okay you know i
mean he never fought francis you see
these things and you go that people were
like he had his but look at him now he's
a [ __ ] monster he's a moyes won one
two three four five in a row monster
goddamn
that anthony smith was brutal
i love it and he's like sorry anthony
smith he's like what sorry i guess it is
what it is damn
you look at his losses all right so he
lost to corey anderson monster wrestler
yeah he lost uh rumble johnson got
knocked out in 13 seconds that could
happen to anybody yeah he lost davis
decision than jon jones decision
he's a tough son of a [ __ ] man yes
yes is anthony johnson still fighting in
the ufc he's the military he's fighting
for the title next in the champ the
russian champions it's a tough match up
for johnson yeah
but johnson just has that god given
power where if he lands the games that
match
god man
crazy
cuckoo crazy that's such a rough
game yeah i love i love um who's this
jim anthony johnson oh yeah
i love all that stuff i love how hard it
is when are we gonna see jon jones man
when he gets paid
he wants more time to get at heavyweight
but yeah when he gets paid is it
possible to get more substances in your
body
do you why do you have something
take it easy dude
dude i don't know you're smoking a bit
of a hookah right now i know right yeah
you keep going is this like all purple
and [ __ ]
is that just is that just so you got
nicotine you put this in your lungs yeah
christian what is this is this nicotine
yes that's just straight nicotine
okay so you you're out of put in my
lungs right but nicotine you're a fan of
because it's good for the brain great
for the brain really really so you do a
little pouch yep how often you have the
pouch in your little mouth i mean i go
through a can a day oh you do what does
it do for the brain
like this if you if you inhaling this
and your lungs bad for you like you're
going to die but um
and what is that that is this would be a
uh a vape yeah well the only way that's
why like killing teenagers and [ __ ] yeah
but the only way you get a buzz if is if
you inhale it it gives me a buzz even
without inhaling it really so you treat
it like a cigar yes
yeah i will not put smoke in my lungs
there's i do have a
rock bottom i have a question have you
guys seen
the new trailer for the cinderella movie
oh with olivia whatever what's your name
about this
put on some weight huh
have you seen who the fairy godmother is
who is it oh yeah homie can you bring it
up oh the guy from where i am for the
show
fantastic no is he from
no no he's not from queer no is he i
don't i don't know it's it's kind of
fantastic
it's it's gutsy
i saw the uh you know what i know what
you're doing and i don't like it what am
i doing i know what you're doing because
you you were labeled pro like far right
then you're trying to go far left
now i'm just asking you to tell me what
you think of the fairy godmother i know
what you're doing he kills it and i
don't like it what am i doing and i know
you're trying to sell more tickets
by appealing to everybody no i'm not i
just believe in everything try to sell
more i know what you're trying to do
if you want to come see me come see me
wait
have you seen
that's the fairy godmother
yeah that would be the fairy god man
well she says she's no she knows his
pronouns aren't or no he's he's he's no
they say they say fairy godmother i
think it's well no that but that doesn't
i think it's ballsy as [ __ ] and i can
just i liked i liked it somebody sat
around and went you know what
what if we just turned him into a super
queenie black dude
everybody's like i think i think they
call him fairy godmother
i know what you're doing
i was asking what you think i'm
literally just an observer you're stupid
no i'm an observer you know what you're
doing you're trying to appeal to the far
left right now and i don't like what's
going on here i'm not
i'm a middle of the road guy i'm just
asking you if you change your pronouns
i'm going to fight you
i do identify as if they and it doesn't
matter oh you do
yeah i do yeah dude
yeah i do now
i do because some days i just feel you
feel it non-binary and that's fine feel
what you feel what i say about that kid
in the gym he's like a little like we
don't know i go he looks like he's in
the fifth round with his pronouns
and he's losing that battle man he's
down four four rounds
yeah
he's like huh brittany i don't like you
you're laughing so much oh he's in the
fifth round of his pronouns right now
because they went you know it's like
it's just like a mystery it's like
mystery me yeah the thing is like no one
was really saying anything but he's just
like
brendan will just like pop out of
nowhere with [ __ ] but like everyone's
kind of thinking it individually
he'll just feel like i texted him
yesterday i said he told me a joke that
he said on on below the belt but they
had to take it out yeah i just thought
it was so good oh i didn't get you to
tell me yeah it's a good joke but i was
like i don't know i just liked it i
don't want to deal with the
repercussions
that's fine yeah you did text me last
night we're all good
oh yeah no i'm saying you're texting
last night about that joke did you get
any do you hurt me i don't pay attention
i don't know
i don't know man i don't either i mean
you know
now are you watching do you watch a lot
of football
still uh
college i'll pay attention to i like
this is what i like i like that every
single stadium whether it's a democratic
state republican state red blue every
single stadium including ucla and you
know la's north korea or the beach
including ucla is packed to the gills
with people without masks
it just shows you that the general
population is over covered they're over
the [ __ ] yeah and they make the decision
i'm not saying i want them to spread
cover cover it's a serious matter but
i'm saying you the the general
population like
we know the repercussions we know the
risk and we're willing to do this well
thanks to the good news is that
with vaccines and also with the um with
all the
therapies that you you can apply it
covet is most likely not going to kill
you thanks to
medicine dude how about how about what
they're doing with tarokin
how about the shitty far left spin on
rogan what are they saying sandy's
taking horse dewormer and it's not real
and ivermectin yeah
dude so you don't that with ivermectin
you know in tokyo the the government
came out and said to take it yeah you
know in florida desantis has been giving
a lot of stuff up they
trump took it like all i know is the
doctor who gave it to him they won a
nobel peace prize in 2015. it's not like
rogan was like researching on the dark
web
and brett weinstein's a scientist and
was like look there's a lot of evidence
that suggests
but also what i think is interesting is
that he was also sick for one day and he
credited
the the antibiotics he credited all the
things he took he said a huge shout out
to western medicine western science yeah
but
i also text rogan this way told me he
had it i said also
you should be proud of yourself same
with you know i know people wish we were
more sick but it is what it is but also
i told you you should grab yourself more
to
your life dedication to health and
working out like that that this is why
we do it dude you're building an armor
so when this stuff comes yes you have an
armor built up you can't just win code
come on i'm gonna get in shape real
quick this doesn't work i don't know if
i talked about this the other day but
like
one of the things i think is interesting
is that you know the best thing you can
do for yourself a lot of times is stay
in shape eat properly and stuff like
that and so when you see somebody with
all due respect who's super nazi about
washing their hands wearing masks social
distancing all good and they're 300
pounds that's 300 pounds you go you know
or or i'm worried about terrorism but
i'm eating nothing but wheat
sugar and corn syrup you go diabetes is
going to get you way sooner than you
should be way more worried about your
cholesterol than whatever's out there
dude and i watch i look at when when
half of americans are literally obese
and we have a weight problem on that
level
you know you've gotta you've gotta you
gotta it goes back to telling the truth
we gotta be honest about what's actually
the bigger threat here statistically you
gotta look at the metadata here man yeah
so
you know again it's like
sometimes we are fighting an
enemy that's not actually as big a
threat as the guy the enemy that's right
well i think with rogan too like the the
left and cnn you know because he he's
not anti-vaccine no he's not
anti-vaccine he's actually pro-vaccine
but he was just saying if you're young
in shape i wouldn't get it like your
odds of surviving it's pretty good i
want to put this in your body but
there's not enough research done with it
fair enough that's his thoughts and
that's fine his point of view so the far
left and cnn
when he got it they're more upset that
he wasn't more sick of course they are
how insane that's the weirdest thing
of course they are
because they think of him as a bro they
think of him as the enemy they think of
him as uh well he can point the finger
call him a right wing they call him
alt-right yeah all those things which
none of it couldn't be further from the
people of which is true
and it's it's again them trying to
control a narrative that isn't working
because he's way bigger than they are
his audience is so much you're dealing
with jealousy you're dealing with fear
on their part and you you're dealing
with haters you know yeah
i also i i'm telling you i also think
that the majority of the people that are
giving you your news
are people that came straight out of a
college classroom they don't know like
they don't live in the real world yeah
they they not really they're not really
out there
when you watch fox or scene on either
side they're both
you wouldn't want to be their friend no
yeah yeah yeah nothing in common on top
of that just remember this fox or cnn
the most important thing is less the
truth and more ratings it's just your
attention
ratings covid afghanistan yeah it's fox
it's anti-biden if you're cnn it's
anti-trump so now trump's gone cnn
ratings are
right
right so what they what they do they had
they had to put a daily a minute by
minute death
yeah but they can't do that anymore
because the deaths aren't there
yeah uh and and so
what i object so they're just they're
constantly you're trying to find an
authority
what i object to is when you have
something that's true so if you were to
say for example the delta variant seems
to be less lethal than the first more
contagious less lethal yeah and if you
say that sometimes you can get flagged
for spreading disinformation i have a
problem with social media or the big
media giants having control of
that narrative you're you're also not
you know now now i'm i'm wondering what
that agenda is well remember those those
media giants are those social media
giants most of them are far far left so
they have an agenda too yes so their
biases get put into that yes for
everybody yes
and you know there's something wrong
with well because you know trump's ban
on twitter but the head of
uh [ __ ] the taliban is not isn't that
amazing isn't that amazing i mean it's
not that i'm the head of television on
twitter i don't like either of them yeah
i would i would like to remind everybody
at
the head of the taliban people are like
well let's see if we can have a
coalition guard what's his nickname um i
don't know his name look up his nickname
yeah
he sacrificed his own son to in a
suicide his own son was a was a uh
bomber yeah yeah
but they're a mere their head spiritual
leader
these aren't exactly what's commander of
the faithful oh yeah oh no that's
something oh yeah no i'm sorry
yeah his son was a uh he was going
through some [ __ ] yeah
one of the ones in they're a harsh
they're a harsh
they're harsh one of the ones that
killed the marines
i'm sorry no his son no
years ago
yeah 2017. i'm talking about another guy
forget his name but his name's like
something the butcher
he did some horrible oh i know he's uh
he's high up in the taliban yeah he was
the guy that was in a [ __ ] that they
were talking about in american sniper
yeah yeah
oh yeah the butcher yeah
that was in iraq yep co-founder
reportedly leads the new government
we're not not the american sniper lone
survivor i think it was no survivor
there you go yeah
that's him
roger the butcher their
yeah he looks like a
pretty
friendly guy yeah but he's great
it's
are you excited for the football let's
change the subject [ __ ] these guys are
you excited for football or no yeah i
love watching football there's something
about that sport i think is [ __ ]
amazing
do you like uh thursday night's the
first game it's the buccaneers versus
the cowboys
ooh this is going to be an interesting
note here because i want to watch
yeah i'm a patriots and box fan like i'm
oh because brady went there yeah i
buried it
i root for brady no matter what is gronk
playing on the bucks again and it's
adrian
is uh
a b um
brown antonio brown
yeah he's on there okay how about all so
far this is what's crazy about in with
the salary cap and the nfl in 2021 is it
possible do this every starter on
offensive defense is back the chance of
them returning is very good wow that's
insane i've gone back to the super yes
because
i want to see how
belichick is going to do without brady
because we know i did last year yeah yes
last year they suck how is that how are
they how are they yeah
they just no they don't have a campaign
yeah
he can't get a team they're matt johnson
who was the quarterback from alabama is
there started now he won the job and
they cut cam newton so this rookie
quarterback but he's from alabama drew
brees co-signed him says he's gonna be
rookie of the year
i didn't even see it at alabama could
you look at the guys he's throwing to
and the defenses i'm not high on them
but so why why was cam newton cut is he
just
i mean yeah he's he's older and then you
know he's he's
he's older
i didn't think he's got his timers right
he's played long on that
i didn't think i honestly didn't be he
was anything special when he played for
the patriots even when he played for
jacksonville no when he played
so
he originally signed with the university
of florida yeah tim and him were i
i think tim was his like guy who showed
him around campus and then cam newton
got kicked out because of a laptop
mishap he got kicked out then went to
university auburn won a heisman there in
the national championship wow but him
and tim were gonna be on the same team
he's only played nine years that's not a
long time it is it is the longest time
no it's the longest time nine years
you're mv dude your mvp went to a super
bowl yeah but i feel like such a good
player still got player he's still got
he's still got [ __ ] in him though right
it's tough injuries you're thinking of
tom brady and then also think he he's a
physical dude dude he's big dude
that picture of him mean him we're at
some function together he's big oh he's
bigger than you right taller taller yeah
leaner
he's leaner than you are
way better looking
and dress as well yeah people clown him
because his outfits that [ __ ] is fun
his hats and [ __ ] he dresses we have the
same hat guy i mean he he uh no he's a
bad [ __ ] but um i just feel like
he's got more in him look at that
you didn't like that one i don't mind he
didn't need to do the thing underneath
the neck if he would have just done
everything but the thing over there but
his hats like there
is pink one no the that one those are
fired wow
man he loves that that suits fire dude
that's fine i like that guy that's
[ __ ] dumb you like that hell yeah i
don't know if i can do that same jacket
that's dope he's a bad guy dude if you
can pull that off why won't you just
like that
romper
what he looks fantastic that's a romper
dog that was not awkward because it has
a dude look at that look at the way he's
the one i don't think it's two pieces
that's what i have the same [ __ ] dude i
have a blue one like that he's gotten
paid yeah look at cause he has the
brennan
oh yeah he made all the money yeah so
now he's mvp dude so now he'll be
walking around he's fantastic he should
do something with fashion too uh you
gotta love this guy he seems like he's a
great guy is he liked by his teammates
i can't answer that okay i would assume
he seems he seems great look at the
weight yeah look at that superman outfit
that [ __ ] is [ __ ] [ __ ] dude that
that's a dope ass i wish i looked like
that no me too i like that jacket i'm
serious
whatever you want to come did you ever
see when he was he does a summer camp
and the kids started talking [ __ ] to him
oh yeah and he goes that's why you blah
blah and he's like bro i was the nfl mvp
you stupid [ __ ]
but he he educated kid he was nice about
it he was my man my man and like broke
it down to him
that's fine
him and russell westbrook dressed a
little similar
he looks like the riddler there
but yeah he doesn't get laid right the
girls
i know i don't know i think he's married
there was just a picture with his girl i
think
if
but i just feel like he's got more in
him man come on
is it because they figure out your
tendencies
look at his girlfriend look at that girl
right there look at that right there huh
hmm
oh this kid's adorable yeah this kid
isn't adorable or anything jesus christ
are you kidding me right now okay are
you kidding me
i just want to [ __ ] quit everything
chin hello real quick
go back real quick i've got to see the
picture from before where she's in just
scroll down for a second please scroll
down where she's in bikini yeah she's
inside on the farm there you go knowing
that right there yeah
knee slapper
well i feel like quitting i want to go
home
are you kidding me right now some
gorgeous women out there and some
gorgeous men and they get together and
make gorgeous babies yeah
and then when he has all the money in
the world so wait he doesn't have a wife
then he's just gonna uh it's his ex yeah
i think he has four kids
well he should have all the kids and he
should have my kid and he should
you know you let him hooked up with you
of course what am i gonna hook up with
your girl yeah i would i really would
what am i going to do i'd watch this
what am i going to do
i'd watch them no stay with me what are
you talking about
look at her though my girl has that
exact same body i'm not going to [ __ ]
you guys yeah congratulations thanks
dude yeah congrats but i don't look like
him no no you're cute kid you're a good
looking guy but compared to dude i'm
telling you i have a picture of me him
wearing suits and i look like a [ __ ]
turd what is going on here
those what is going on talking about
them big tits oh
yeah the whole situation is a problem
huh
what's going on dude i think she's
single bro oh my god look at the gene
short one chin
yeah i don't know i mean how do you fit
in those i don't know i don't know
what's going on she's getting specially
made dog
what's going on with her dance like
those are real yeah
possibly did i tell you what that guy
said to my girlfriend oh columbia tell
them like i said
you built like a brick [ __ ] house get
that kool-aid smile
who said that dude what generation are
you from oh
smile you built like a brick [ __ ] house
i mean some old reference
wow damn she is lean yeah she is she's
jacked
oh what the [ __ ] is going on
keep going chin this is him yeah this is
fantastic there's a lot of
i mean i don't they're kids a lot of
it's filtered too though just being real
here hater chips just being real i
always got to come here
you can't even look up right now you're
hating on this [ __ ]
you can't even stare at the sun these
days you hate
though you see these girls on instagram
that are insane then you see them in
real life oh yeah yeah i've been in life
she's not a bombshell she's definitely a
bomb you know i'm thinking
i bet she's smoke
ten thousand sometimes oh you're
beautiful sometimes they're better
looking she's she's phenomenal though
what is her name
lorena
yeah of course it is all these girls oh
damn
you like her miss cargill birthday trip
aspen
libra
nice underscore cargo i mean
i mean there it is their kids look
adorable
all right chin get off the [ __ ] side
no one's even talking anymore i know
isn't that funny
just looking
oh look i feel like he's got more game
in him who's going to pick him up
somebody is it because
is it because they find out what his
tendencies are on his people
dude 10 years man
that's forever drew brees has been
playing for 20. well drew become very
tired so those are exceptions i know
this is the problem with the couch
dude what about tom brady what about
drew brees first of all they're pocket
quarterbacks i know oh so cam newton got
hit more times than any other
quarterback in a single year his last
year at carolina that's going to take
some damage no because they have a
shitty old line and then he has to run
and he hold the ball takes all the
damage and he's a big dude yeah oh so he
breaks down yeah he's stupid what so he
breaks down he's not but his body can
only take so much man
like drew brees and tom braither like
tom's not why comrades are [ __ ] right
when you say their pocket quarterbacks
they just sit back they jump they got
their great old lines and they're and
they're so smart in the same football
the ball's out before they get hit right
they'll throw it to the silent for they
get [ __ ] lit up and
i'm not saying cam newton is not a smart
quarterback but like tom brady and drew
brees they know exactly
the best when they know that they got to
get the ball out in a nanosecond
otherwise you can get lit up or you see
tom and uh drew if someone's coming
there's no coverage don't they'll get
down before they get so with cam what
they what part of his job is to get
yards any way he can including running
through people again and sometimes you
know he's playing with [ __ ] like
caroline was terrible dude so he's just
getting [ __ ] lit man
but it's it's like you look at uh jameis
winston who's a baller for tampa he
threw like for all the yards threw for a
million touchdowns a lot of
interceptions it was like i don't get it
man he's just not a winner they find out
oh he can't see he can't see he has very
bad vision so he got lasik surgery now
he's the starting quarterback for the
saints and he's going to light it
[ __ ] up saints are going to be good
damn you find out he's been playing this
entire time with horrible vision wow
what's your prediction on dak prescott
uh
it's tough like did he deserve all that
money i like when guys get paid but
remember like with the dallas cowboys
and with zeke elliott like his numbers
are almost like they're good right like
the numbers are good but they're down a
lot so they're passing a ton so these
numbers can be really good but they're
playing from behind you know what i'm
saying so it's like he threw for 400
yards like yeah but they lost by 18 dude
so they're playing from
far down so they're not running it so of
course
why but they're not winning why are they
not running they don't have the
offensive line to create holes no they
do their their offense is good this year
their defense sucks but they did draft
that kid from uh oh yeah lsu i think i'm
a skinny guy yeah he's a stud he's a
stud super stud [ __ ]
monster
how about that and i'm watching hard
knocks and that that kid from the ivory
coast he's a he's an undersized he's 230
pounds hilariously one player for
yeah which is undersized actually yeah
but they're getting smaller and quicker
it's all about speed then it feels all
speed but again
like you look at him
the days of the real big guy are kind of
but you look at him he's such a freak
looking meanwhile he's probably not
going to make it meanwhile that's what
hard knocks does they get to invest in
no player and then they cut him i also
didn't know that when you're in when
you're playing with the dallas cowboys
and practicing i thought you were on the
team no no no you're not
you're in training camp and you get
caught oh yeah and you know like you
kind of know and that's what happened
right he just who tim tebow he just got
yeah yeah but there's there's three cuts
so there's usually three preseason games
or four and then each precinct game to
the final game
yeah
stutt he's got a great story you know
all that stuff and that's a tough thing
you got invested in that that's from
arizona that's a tough gig too it's that
time
i don't know if he was drafted or what
but it's a tough gig because there's no
there's a 53-man roster
so like i knew tim was getting cut
because they didn't have on special
teams you did
i knew because when they just had them
play on offense and not special teams
dude
only the starters don't play special
teams like you gotta contribute somehow
and i was like oh he's not on kickoff
kick return punt punt return
you're [ __ ] dude
and is it because
i feel like being a tight end is
you know you block and then you you just
got to know your routes yeah and you're
big and strong enough to catch the ball
yep why he's so big and strong he had
five years off man stuff compete with
guys who doing it you know they just got
that god bless him though i mean he was
close you know
yeah
wow
happens
any other [ __ ] questions
that's so competitive
and that what bothers me is i'm never
going to make it on any of these [ __ ]
teams
here's the thing here's i'm going to
slap you with a cold day in your face
okay
oh god you have a cold cold wet [ __ ] in
your face yeah how do you get it
in there you keep it in someone's dick
keep it in some ice okay and but you
take viagra so it's big enough
to keep you got to stay hard
i'ma hit you with that polar bear dick
here's the thing
oh you're never gonna look like cam
newton
you're never gonna get his girl
you don't know [ __ ] about locker room
sports you just do but i'm a guy
what's up guys what are we doing you
know that kind of stuff yeah guys let's
get out there and win it
let's go let's go
every team needs that huh
yeah man hey fellas i see a lot of you
out there starting to lose your hair man
you know two out of three bros will
experience some form of hair loss by the
time they're 35 more than 50 million
dudes in the us suffer from male pattern
baldness that's not good thank god for
keeps keeps offers a simple stress-free
way to keep your locks man low-cost
treatments start just ten dollars per
month keeps offers generic versions
discreet little package shows up proven
results keeps has more five-star reviews
than any of its competitors prevention
is key treatments can take four to six
months to see results so act right now
before all your hair is gone if you're
ready to take action prevent hair loss
go to keeps.com fighter that's k-e-e-p-s
dot com fighter
to receive your first month of treatment
for free that's keeps.com fighter get
your first month free
k-e-e-p-s dot com fighter
hey man your online checking account
shouldn't cost you money that's why
chime an award-winning app and debit
card has no overdraft fees foreign
transaction fees monthly service fees
transfer fees we got you covered man
they have over 60 000 fee free and
network atms at locations like walgreens
7-eleven cvs and so much more that's
more than the top three national banks
combined can also send money to anyone
even if they aren't on chime no fees for
you or cash out fees for them alright
it's time to say goodbye to hidden fees
join the millions of americans already
loving chime sign up takes only two
minutes doesn't affect your credit score
get started today at chime dot com
fighter that's chime dot com slash
fighter
banking service provided by and debit
card issued by bank corp bank or stride
bank n a members fdic out of network atm
withdrawal fees apply except that money
pass atm in a 7-eleven location and at
any all point or visa plus alliance atm
other fees such as third-party and cash
deposit fees may apply again chime.com
fighter what's up thinkies this thursday
friday saturday san jose california san
jose improv david lucas chappelle lace
out laceys and myself will be all up in
norcal san jose come get some tickets at
fatkz.com
and the built thick boy collab tees
dropped this friday friday morning all
the built club tees are available at
thickboy.com
this episode of fighting kit is brought
to you by the one the only the most
badass system supplements on the planet
we talk about on it what do you need
dude you need to get your brain right
get some alpha brain you need up your
mood get new mood you need total gut
health we got shroom tech we got krill
oil joint oil we got creatine protein
powders up the gazoo we have mood and
sleep enhancers keto if you're keto like
myself they got the keto collection we
got nutrition for you man we got mc2 tea
oil whey protein plant-based protein
protein bars protein bites we got coffee
protein power puffs we got elk bars
warrior bars we even got fitness for
your thick ass kettlebells steel club
maces quad maces battle ropes streaming
fitness so you don't have to go into the
gym anymore do it from your crib on it
in 30. we got on it on demand workouts
streaming fitness programs we've got you
covered there's no reason not to get
your thick ass in shape this year on
it.com fighter 10 off dude what if the
la rams asked you to do like uh
the celebrity cheerleader i'll eat a
dick what no yeah you backflip oh you're
oh oh i'm oh my bad you want to do you
want to fight again you wouldn't do it
you want to fight again sure no you
don't [ __ ] i thought you meant
you right now no not me
no i don't want to do that exactly would
you do it how about you could do it
first of all i didn't do that
that wasn't me
that wasn't me
hey
yeah
fairy godmother huh
that uh
guy cheerleader over there no he kills
it
him
that's not what i that's not what i did
i had no problem with it i think
best looking squad right probably not
probably what do you mean not the best
bro i remember when i was playing
college ball but okay
you want me to do that yeah i do but i
remember when we played at university of
kansas
the
coach barnett would have to be like hey
pay attention because they're
cheerleaders we're we're so [ __ ]
fired usually kansas the jayhawks oh the
jayhawks yeah like everyone just their
head would be like hey you [ __ ] we're
up two points pay attention like yo
sorry what do you want from us
uh do you have uh do you have who if
who's your money on this weekend with
the donald trump uh calling the fights
between the people
i think vitor knocks him out you do yeah
knocks him out yeah but vander's much
better boxer
oh wait they're allowed to knock out 30
years ago he was a very good boxer
now i said something below the bell and
i don't know
i did it i was at a charity function
with evander holyfield and jay jay can
co-sign this we're at the function we're
all dressed up looking like penguins and
i see him i go oh [ __ ] evander holyfield
and i go over there and he's mumbling
like that's weird and he had to have a
handler whispering in his air telling
who he is where to go so should he be
fighting now
what the commission of california didn't
grant him a license so that didn't go to
florida i didn't know that that makes
sense have you seen vitor training
he's on all the sauce so he's on all the
acai and
outside yeah
okay skyler don't post that but then
vitoria can [ __ ] bang dude yeah he
can crack because he's only he's still
fighting bro have you seen his wife
it was
it was unreal when we were trained in
vegas and his wife would come cage side
and throw coaching tips at them unreal
dude
it was crazy oh my god you know i don't
i remember seeing her she's uh
it's on i mean your vitoria can i see
something you you know his sister got
kidnapped in brazil and murdered him
i think about it all the time [ __ ] i
think about it all the time look at his
beautiful kids oh
well he's the nicest guy in the world
he's the nicest guy in the world his
son's playing football isn't he i think
so he's a super stud quarterback is he
really yeah yeah i knew something and
you know i played volleyball with his
dad and his dad was in a white sunga at
probably 70 years old nuts hanging out
the side and beat the [ __ ] out of us in
volleyball is that right yep and and uh
no it's hanging out this stuff
for some reason we kept calling him
belfor belfor
and his son is a stud quarterback um
yeah i think he's going to notre dame
he's super stunned he's that good yeah
he's like top five like bring up what
super stud oh that's huge that's great
dude vitor is a freak
no he's a freak he's a freak well you
know you train with him
oh dude
yeah pick some alabama offer
alabama university of alabama ever heard
of them oh my god
you know how hard it is to get a
scholarship oh my god you know what
impossible is to get a scholarship
impossible oh dude alabama
and and and no hold on bama
he's dude look at this
dave davey belfor has not played a high
a single high school football game but
he does have one of the greatest college
coaches of all time trying unless his
service bell for a rising freshman
cardinal newman received an offer from
alabama before he even played a goddamn
that's how talented the kid is [ __ ] let
me see him dude i would be a kid big kid
there he is he's dude he's in eighth
grade he's the biggest kid oh he's in
eighth grade he's going to high school
oh i thought he was like
coming out of high school dude here's
dude if if mice if tiger boston went to
uc alabama i would get the [ __ ]
elephant logo tattooed on the side of my
neck i would paint my face every game
i'd wear elephant trunk i'd wear their
jerseys take it easy man dude
i dressed up like bear bryant for every
[ __ ] wow he's only 16 years old and
he's a big kid already dude his dad but
you got you gotta realize that that's
his dad
is such a three kid look at the kid he's
16. look at how he look how big his legs
are that's nice you made a big kid look
how big his legs are he's a stunt
he's just dude signed with [ __ ]
university of alabama as a look at this
ninth grader
i mean come on
now that's the move you fight he plays
football he's gonna make real money
he'll make more money than his dad if he
gets the nfl in a [ __ ] year correct
and his dad is a legend
wow you know vitor bell for his dad
belford belfort we kept calling him
because i couldn't remember his name his
dad's the one who got me a big
sponsorship with uh boni acai no way we
played volleyball his uh [ __ ] and
balls were in our face well i spiked it
and then
this is that and then he was like killer
i mean yeah you know yeah and then yeah
and then uh took us over to get acai and
was like you you need more money i'm
like i always need money and then he got
us the contract what a great guy
belford belfort what a great guy
there's that like that that the old man
beat the [ __ ] on me now now can i on the
beach oh and then had it had the had a
girlfriend
in a
was a but it was a shoestring and her
ass
was the best ass you've ever seen in
your life and we had to pretend we
didn't see it because we don't want to
offend them that's right so as he she
would talk to us we would stare at the
sun like chin
we'd go like this i can't stay with the
sun remember
no yeah well just eyes i'm a fan yeah
all the way around i'm a fan the whole
family's fantastic damn yeah they went
through the worst most special tragedy
yeah i'm pretty sure like is when he was
rising to fame they the you know just
some banditos and brazil took his sister
said hey we need all the money and even
i think they did give bring that up jen
they gave him the money they still
murdered his sister
brazil's wild dude yeah
dude the security we have to have when i
was fighting brazil was on have you ever
seen the gangs
there it's like 50 people with me you
know here check this out check this out
you know we have to take a different
route because we can't go through the
tunnels because what the criminals do
there is they block both interests in
the tunnels and then come up with guns
and rob people so we well the fighters
we have to take different routes to
avoid tunnels because they're worried
criminals are going to plug the tunnels
and rob us
[ __ ] dude
vitor belfort's sister priscilla
disappeared january 20 2004 she was
never found again three years later in
207 elaine pavia confessed to having
been involved in her kidnapping and
murder according to the woman vito
belfor's sister owed four thousand
dollars to drug dealers which served as
the motive for the kidnapping she was
allegedly killed thereafter and her body
was buried in the woods rio de janeiro
despite conducting multiple sources
police were were unable to do brazil's
what it's a beautiful place oh it's very
dangerous like do you hear this this uh
this timepiece girl this dime piece
turned down one of the like cartel guys
there was like no i don't want to go on
a date
cool
they came back and murdered her yeah oh
just get you turned on a date
yeah break your heart it's now brazil is
fantastic though i don't want to paint
that brazil was fantastic even though i
was fighting basically michael jordan of
chicago but i was fighting the same in
brazil yeah they were so nice to me
really even after you lost and stuff
they were really cool amazing so nice to
meet you man one of the most special
places i've ever been so cool frank
guerilla says that he loves dude oh my
god paradise oh yeah i love the people
man i love brazilians the food the
people the most beautiful women in the
world the language is beautiful every
day you go to the beach every guy's in
shape like every [ __ ] like they're
killed
surfing
but then you know the camera the favelas
the favelas are kind of oh wow
that was a tough they're very tough the
favelas are tough
we went into the favelas yeah you have
to get okayed by like the lead favela
guy by the gangs well you see it i saw
these two cops there and you saw what do
you see on instagram one [ __ ]
gangster of another with guns on them
like that as they were walking
you know it's run by it's run by those
those those very organized cartels
um
so is there is there any video of vitor
training hitting pads because he can
describe
boxing team right uh brazilian i don't
know he's a [ __ ] stud though and his
wife's a dying piece this kid's a stud
so no matter what happens you can be
sitting all right
anyone want to bet he beats evander
holyfield so you i should i should be
betting on him eh
no i want to bet you that he wins
uh-huh uh-huh so what do you mean
someone take holyfield
what's the what's good come on you beat
tyson how much you want you want to bet
you are you trying to get me to bet
do you want brian a bit who wants i feel
like christian wants to bet how much you
want to bet
what's worth your time
i don't want to offend you
i don't know that's may 29th though so
it's funny
i'd have to look more into holyfield's
see how he's training have we seen
holyfield at all now the sun triller so
let's look at let's see let's see what
evander looks like yeah because i i'm
uh
just a quick
you're stupid oh you don't like what you
see on film from vitor of l4 yeah oh
cause you know box oh that's right dude
you got the eye
box yes i know a little bit one of the
greatest strikers in the world of all
that yeah what do you mean
oh yeah no oh yeah yeah
you're getting dude in mixed martial
arts vitor belfort you're getting a
little kid tomorrow i did a spinning
wheel kick and knocked out michael
bisping and blinded the man he did do
that but he also got knocked out by
anderson silva and a lot of others oh i
know answer's a chump you're talking
about prime minister when he uh kicked
him in the face yeah oh prime anderson
but other guys oh yeah him up too who
else a lot of guys who else vitor is a
he lost his record is oh so he's not
good no i'm not saying that i'm just
saying that evander is no joke look at
him dude right now
holy [ __ ] hey brendan april hey wow bet
brandon bet i bet your friend i bet your
grand brandon i'm gonna tell you this
right now you know what i'll bet your
gran and if it goes decision i gotta see
him training bro
i gotta see him training because i think
you're gonna be in for a real [ __ ]
song i bet the last training is him
against andy ruiz he sparred with andy
yeah he did he did sparta andy
all right let's see what's going on here
the uh seven months ago seven months ago
that's him he's moving pretty [ __ ]
well
take that bit stop playing
i'm talking about advantage holyfield
guys i'm talking about a real box we we
all know he's better than tyson correct
ruiz yeah he's smart with ruiz louise is
no joke oh my god andy ruse is
this must be old ass footage that they
just posted at
in january
i like the way i like it
it looks so old the footage looks so old
and andy's in too good and you don't
have any tattoos right there there you
go
there you go go to where it said evander
holyfield go back gin it said 20 21.
go up the 421 see it right there
this one yup
i'm gonna tell you now
all right
there you go
there you go
he's intense
his eyes are intense dude
dude he's been boxing all his life bet
on it he looks look at his [ __ ] body
bro
oh dude best body and i mean him or
tommy morrison
yeah bro i know best bodybuilder dude he
could finish fourth and olympia when he
fought tyson
correct
natural
now let me tell you something right now
makes myself this kind of sucks
go back one i need to see him moving
though me too now let me ask you this
are they going to really fight it also
looks really old it is it's going to be
a banger they're going to try to knock
each other out that i would assume
god how good was that shadowbox boring
but [ __ ] look at klitschko
i mean i would tell you the time my
buddy was dating hayden panetta that's
when she broke up with glitch go and he
calls me goes dude
this black suv keeps following me around
i think it's one of klitschko's guys if
klitschko gets out can i call you help
me out
[Laughter]
absolutely not dude absolutely not
no
but nothing happened though right
obviously no he's gotta look good
uh holyfield his house in atlanta was
nutsos i think rick ross uh you said
he's got 11 kids yeah she's 11. from
different i bet that's so fun oh okay
okay yeah
i'm going to take you up on that part
which day you said i might take you up
on the bed i want to do a little more
research on vanderbilt nope how should
we know
you know thank you i don't i don't know
anything you're just i have no idea what
it is i don't know i'm not going to do a
grind with you he's like 59.
oh he's fighting no we're not doing
great let's bet something that's funny
that's fun for you
this green's fun for me well i'm just
like uh
58. he's 58. he's 60 years old sorry
dude it's a vander though how old is
vitor 48 no 54 i think 44 no he's you
know you know evander holyfield's son
played college football at georgia 44
really that's a huge age difference dude
not you you don't talk about the best
this is bad i bet you what's the top
vape pen what do you mean like what's
the best vape pen you can get i have no
idea no vaping i don't know hey if de la
hoya i'll take it out [ __ ] beat the
shot deltoid is an easier fight for him
is that right i'll
after the fight i'll go and i'll get the
like i'll go to the shop i go to and
i'll get the best one okay so that's the
bet all right the best vape that that
store has right whether it's 300 or 40
dollars that's the deal
don't be bullshitting don't be like yeah
give me the ten dollars no i wouldn't
have i'm not i'm just like yeah so
homeboy homes
let me ask them
so evander holyfield i mean i'm sorry de
la hoya is an easier fight no i made
that up
he's a killer
of uh oscar yeah i think 20 years ago
he's in cocaine
yeah he's still still got that language
though
maybe
yeah still understands how to protect
himself 511. dude you're underestimating
vitor
his hands are so fast they're fast and
then you know
he's probably gonna be on yeah dude a
sauced up veto you know good he was yeah
his decline came when they started
cutting all that [ __ ] off and that's
right that's true 44 year old true need
to wear belford it's true i don't think
you understand how fast his hands are
they're crazy right dude will you train
with them fast hands i've ever seen
really fastest i've ever that's a big
problem
i love the guy
keeps changing what does that mean
so you have to put a you have to put 120
dollars to make 100 bucks yeah on a
vander okay so evander's a slight
favorite
vitor's favorite at first then evander's
favorite and now it's it just keeps
switching that's
four years older than me
and i'm slowing down i know it's hard
for you guys to believe it is hard to
believe this [ __ ] i'm not joking
but
your hands my hands are still stupid
what do you think's to happen with
anderson tito
well we saw anderson reese i couldn't
believe how good answered yeah i think
anderson because tito
and i anderson can box the religion
fight roy jones jr remember when it was
that was all signed sealed delivered and
then dana nixon yeah that was prime
anderson inbox look i mean he beat
uh chavez jr that's a that's saying a
lot say something but i i don't think
i'm not taking anything away from the
win i don't think julio cesar chavez jr
took it serious and by the time he
realized he was in a fight he was like
[ __ ] okay and answer and still beat him
up yeah so i think first of all i think
anderson was always a better boxer than
than than tito and tina's not a bad
boxer apparently tito's a good boxer i
mean but i think it's different level
i think also that tito is probably more
injured he's more calcified than than
he feels a little bit tighter than i
think
i think anderson is doing it for the
love he loves boxing loves boxing he
loves the art the other guy's doing it
for desperation
i never bet on the desperation
no
not not when you're fighting i love tito
but tough fight for well you're fighting
for money versus you know
yeah we'll have to watch it in the green
room in san jose yeah let's see what's
up there was some talk about one of the
paul brothers trying to fight
silva logan bad idea logan yeah
that's that's
risky
super risky that's very risky
i would say because anderson's like he
won't be able to use his size no i would
say i would say logan has to train a
couple more years it's weird to me
anderson it's weird to me uh people when
we talk about goats people forget the
rud anderson was on like in his prime
dude did i tell you i finished everybody
dude i had front row tickets i don't
know why at the time danny gave me front
row tickets when anderson fought vitor
and i brought lex mcmahon you know
lexa's bad vision and we're watching and
you see
foo the upkeep and knocks feature out
and go oh my god that's the best
knockout i've ever seen and lex goes
he's staring at the cage goes what
happened
amigo and i go that's how fast i went
dude you shouldn't be sitting here
he's that and i've never been in a fight
with him again yeah
well dude dude i mean the guy was just
faster and better vision excuse me into
the pocket
people forget it's like
but i think he gets taken on the
conversation because the pd stuff
i hate when they do that though me too
because you know everybody's fighting
with on pd of course and also
also like oh it doesn't take away from
general he's great
he's great he's to me
our boy eric williams who eric yeah
derek you if you send this i will put in
the [ __ ] studio i already got the
kimbo one below the belt he has him in
the answer we're very close he has a
picture of anderson silva you know they
call him you know the spider he has a
picture with ann silva with the real
spider-man mask on and it's half he's
pulling it off oh [ __ ]
i've seen it it's the best ancient silva
picture you've ever seen yeah here's
another one with he's a great
photographer eric williams is a great
photographer the best yeah literally the
best he's not because he's my boy but
he's the best dude he has a picture of
wanderlei silva in his prime and his
nickname was zack's murder and he's like
this and his nickname was zack's
murderer and he's covered in blood
bro
bro
it's so good i know
and then remember there's rumors that
gsb and esther and silva are going to
fight each other and they're both in
their prime
only air could pull this off it was that
ruka gym it's a
prime
uh anderson silva prime gsb facing off
when no one saw it and he's like dude
i'm gonna show you something no one's
seen these don't talk about it and it's
[ __ ] them doing their thing oh his
work is [ __ ] amazing yeah he's a
great dude great photographer he makes a
living doing it i mean he's literally
one of the top guys in the game mike
gibbs my gifts
look at that [ __ ] ice cube picture
where he's oh there's a photograph no
the one at the police station
he's photographed everyone christopher
milani
chris is a buddy of mine
i love that guy
damn cool
does he put any of his uh
instruments he was rhonda's personal
photographer gsps chuck liddells
that's all
it's [ __ ] dope
he is the cutest kid
you're not posting the mma ones
uh
christian found the anderson one
so you said anytime peter nope right
yeah
i want that print so bad that's rhonda
cutting weight
wow
there you go
so dope amazing that one's autographed
oh yeah yeah pretty sick
all right give some current advantage
too all righty
eric i need those prints
well you guys already talked about this
but that's what he says how the world
did they did
i don't know how true they can afford
all this they must be like about to
implode right to get donald trump and
his son
yeah i don't know what's gonna happen
but now will the trump fan base tune in
just for of course on there of course
just going to crush i'm not a trump fan
and i'm tuning in
he's going to be commenting on all four
fights you can say whatever you want
about trump i got plenty of criticism he
makes me laugh oh yeah he's very
entertaining well that's what shane gill
says and especially he goes out of all
the presents you go back to him he's the
funniest oh dude he'd be the one you
want to have a beer with because he's
just funny
i told you my buddy i don't have a beer
with jimmy he's driving around martial
and he goes he'd be like driving you
know how lucky you were
will troublesome you know how lucky you
were to be here
you know how lucky you are you guys are
lucky you're lucky you're okay
okay
okay
so this is getting some flack though
from obviously just people because it's
on the fight is on september 11th and
people are giving crap because why would
you do a commentating gig for a fight on
september 11th when you could do
something bigger to honor the you know
the people that passed marriages and
shut up i know it's just it's this
that's the news what would he do the
greatest country in the world yeah what
do you want him to do
this was a former president though yeah
i was chosen to do
on the 20th anniversary i don't know
that picture's
kind of funny too great dude that's such
a big get it
come on dude
what
what first first a man for the fairy
godmother and uh
trump calling a [ __ ] fight i love
america
like on their phone that's the worst
[ __ ]
it's just it looks like a tank abbott
poster it does like from the 90s like
the 90s no no holds barred
most anticipated fight of the year well
president trump hosts the most wow
holy [ __ ] dude how much did they have to
pay i don't know how they're going to
survive that makes no sense
it makes sense they see this all the
time like affliction they throw all the
money and then
why would they get it for free why would
they do that why do you say you don't
think trump did it for free i can't
imagine him doing free man you go on
youtube live and get more views that
looks literally like they're getting
them but they have to give them a piece
of paper or something family people
won't tune in
oh yeah
no trump's a business just a bunch of
that stuff
anyhow
the left's upset okay so this one i try
to
read the entire article i kind of get
what's going on but i'm not 100 sure so
this is an actor who's able to get 650
million dollars in a ponzi scheme
because he told people that he would he
was doing these different movies on
netflix right and some other some other
like uh shows
and then he took from he had people
believe him that he was in these movies
and he's putting it yeah but they're
also his family members relatives like
friends and stuff like that so he was
able to get 650 million dollars from all
these people from family and friends and
other people investors he just believes
his lies and he's an actor like an actor
for sci-fi movies and stuff like that
damn yeah he was actually interested i
was going to prison he was actually in
yeah
this guy yeah this guy
so he can face up his 20 years in prison
his eyebrows man
wow he can face up for 20 years but the
fact that he can
get that much money that many people to
believe
yeah so when they did an investigation
they realized that yeah he has no
affiliation with netflix what's he
saying
this movie that yeah he has he's he has
he's partnered he's partnered with all
these different places like netflix and
some other you know other like
production houses and then people just
gave him a ton of money [ __ ]
and then he bought like really nice
houses and
yeah
650 million
i mean people are crazy yeah dude see
investors think of this
do you know how many i was just in this
podcast 30s of a third time they go on
like conspiracy theories and stuff like
that do you know how many missing
children every year
just go missing a lot but have you ever
yeah a lot of it is a parent who take
their kids so a lot of that stat if you
look at those statistics a lot of it is
a family member usually a parent that
absconds with their own child oh [ __ ]
not the majority of it though a lot of
all these kids never know actually the
majority of it is but you're right that
there are a lot of children that do
disappear
so eight we're eight million every year
every year million so let's just say
ten percent of that
let's say ten percent are murdered
eight hundred while using thousands of
people the ordeal can sometimes last
months even years yeah how nuts is that
yeah although i will say that to that
child sex trafficking
yes but so here's the other thing about
that stat
um child uh pornography
the horrible thing is it's usually done
by a family member or parents and so
yeah
that's how awful that is jesus and and
and child pornography is a massive
massive problem and market on the black
uh thing but but your child being
abducted by a stranger is actually very
very low it happens of course and it's
horrible but for the most part a lot of
the stuff is i got another factor you
guys yeah you know one out of every 10
murders goes on unsalted yeah
in mexico
oh i've said i thought it'd be higher
nine out of 10 people get away with it
oh that's how yeah i'm gonna say yeah my
bad nine out of ten get away with murder
in mexico that doesn't surprise me
isn't that nuts it's hard
eight million kids missing every year
have you ever seen how many i don't know
i know all this stuff do you know how
many people go missing in national
forests in america every year so
eighty-one percent dude it's 12 months
old because i was going to yellowstone i
looked it up dude it's this goat they go
into the forest like gruesome people are
individuals individuals they've gone
they get like disoriented it's gone dude
we don't know
there's theories around it and that's
what the podcast was i'm just gone dude
[ __ ] insane nuts
[ __ ] going to the forest floor some
people think it's about mine some people
think it's other things they think maybe
there's a national park serial killer
they don't know
i like that theory to do type in how
many people go missing in national
[ __ ] parks every year what podcast is
this
theories of a third kind
it's three people it's great though kind
of kind of interested oh it's fun
because one guy you don't you won't ever
give away his identity he was in a cult
growing up and escaped oh damn
in the united states nuts dude
nuts bro
so this is a missing period mississippi
person has often found national parks
national parks 1600 people a lot of
people are currently missing yeah but
they they get found
some of them
and and oh some get found some of them
one thousand americans have vanished
without a trace probably eaten
see that's what people think but
you know uncommon a [ __ ] bear attack
is dude it's i mean it's super people in
forest
you know i went camping in yosemite once
and i'm not even joking so my friends
were
doing their thing getting stuff their
tents put up and everything i had to
take a dump there's no bathrooms because
it's like a really like foresty area so
i wanted to walk in
pretty far deep so no one sees me i took
a dump
and then i came i was like looking for a
campground i couldn't find it oh that's
terrifying i was freaking out i was like
ah and finally someone said
i could hear them and i went towards
that direction i got lost just by trying
to get down
with this indonesian rainforest that's
even crazier yep i'm in the old
indonesian rainforest i went go for a
pee pee
and i got lost
and
i was like i'm sure where i was going
was where i was going and i and my
sister just heard kathleen
adelaine and the diax who are the
indigenous people of that area they came
and found me in a couple of seconds wow
chin will you go back to that search
because i wonder what park has the most
missing people i'm pretty sure it's
yellow or yeah yellowstone which
national park uh well it was on scroll
down it was down there that's not a huge
area uh go to which national park is
most
lake mead
where's like me dude
three people going
oh really lake mead national workers
wins the top side with five or six dude
oh no i'm thinking like me period like
me how's it not more awareness dude yeah
where is this 600 people just missing in
the [ __ ] forest
on a mission [ __ ] crazy about this
yeah
always drop breadcrumbs eight million
kids gone every year
ooh piece of cake we're worried about
coven yeah
well
you know it might be
aliens wait where is it where's that
arizona it is it's the same it's the
same it's worth the hoverboard five
million acres of mountains dude it's a
lot that's like kid [ __ ] i remember when
i was uh younger and uh a girl in my
neighborhood in mesa like not too far
from my crib uh got abducted never never
found her name
my biggest nightmare it was it was
insane like
like literally i think i don't even
think it was like fully nighttime i
think you know the sun was coming down a
little bit
and she was just out front on her
bicycle i think her sister might have
ran his side for like a second and then
next thing you know like the bike it was
just the bike outside yeah is is this
your biggest nightmare
insane dude it was like it was like the
scariest thing in the neighborhood
because it was just like
yeah oh dude it was it was
yeah i think about yeah and they never
um they i don't yeah they never found
anything your parents are more
everything i mean granted eight million
kids go missing i don't know what was
when we were kids how many kids went
missing in the 90s but now i feel like
people are more savvy to it yeah
hopefully parents are more aware of it
yeah this had to be 98 when that because
like you'd be happy when i dropped i
never found her they never found it uh
or certainly michelle [ __ ] right
yeah this is i mean it's just a sad
[ __ ] story
22 uh years ago she was you know 22 22
years ago yeah
so it's actually dropped yeah because
people became more aware in america for
sure yeah because i like when i dropped
my son off at school you know for his
first day of kindergarten
you know i know his teach i met with his
teachers from the school i met the other
parents i was like my daddy's like my
man you walk to school or you when
you're when you were five you walked two
miles
i don't think i could tell your
teacher's name i never met him i'm like
what when you were five yeah
he was like your brother
i have no idea like you just did your
thing
i was like man
i like what it takes i dropped her off i
know his teacher's name i text her i
know what where he's at at all times i
know the other kids in the class i know
they're i have their teachers their
parents numbers
it's nuts dude my dad was just like see
ya
yeah it was just different just
different time
different time it was more dangerous
back then
yeah
cameras
yeah
now getting cell phones yeah cops do
that they just follow the cameras
yeah and cell phones let's go boop boop
boop boop and find you oh that long
beach couple that was gunned down just
over a parking thing and 99. it happened
in 99 yeah did they find her no never
found her still missing
it's crazy she said a lot of that's that
sex trade [ __ ] yeah she is
that's what they they've leaned it's
usually some psycho [ __ ] she was like
outside and then her sister turned went
inside came back you literally like
literally
they said the tire was still spinning
yeah that's funny they said that's how
quick it was really i mean your family
some guy stopped his car and pulled her
in
how old was she
uh what is it how old she was it was
literally like right it was like
but i don't have his set of skills but
me too you guys stopped guessing
my life's over my life so yeah my life's
there's a set of skills lifestyle uh
what did he say i'm trying to find her
age i don't at the time see it yeah i
remember posting the uh pictures around
in our neighborhood about 12 dudes it's
not a big deal
not 12 huh no that's a very young girl
she's younger
that's what's called inconsolable grief
you know people die of heart broken
hearts over that stuff yeah elizabeth
smart's grandmother died of grief
she died of grief she died of a
heartbroken heart all right let's change
the subject let's uh ah whiskey
the whiskey's nice huh
yeah cheers boys
are you guys deaf people think you're
drinking beer you're drinking water
joke's on you
yeah i used to get down with that
arrogant bastard it's a good ipa right
yeah better yeah the other like that
stone idea i think it's something that i
can't you don't do those okay maybe now
well it's okay this is
this is an older video but it's it's
becoming viral on tick tock right now
but i remember the sharks like trying to
get out yeah you guys saw this all right
we're a sniper and the shark's like dear
god get me out of here but the fact that
the whole team on the boat didn't even
know if someone's actually in the cage
they're like i don't think it was in
there oh they're lost wait someone's in
there
[ __ ] names like get me out of here
what's he pop in
you'll see
i would like to do this one day what do
i mean first
you've done it brian no no
you didn't clear the shark
oh the stars
yeah i shouldn't get out it's all cut up
[Music]
and someone says no one's in the cage
[Music]
oh my god
oh so the shark was just freaking out
trying to get out yeah yeah he wasn't
trying to attack yeah yeah but that
truck will [ __ ] you up but can you
imagine so he's getting out right now
this guy can you imagine being in there
in that cage with that damn shark i mean
nightmares
crocodile horse great whites
i would love to do that though
yeah it's wait what happens is so in
south africa you go you tell them the
water the sharks already know they're
like ah here the boats they come in and
then um you get in you get a wetsuit you
get in
you're there
in the water cage is already there set
up yeah on the shark and the sharks know
yeah it'd be cool to see it's cool but
you know what's cooler oh you did it on
top you did it yeah now you know what
you did with great whites
okay now
i know but you know so oh so you saw
great whites when you did it in
australia it was south africa let me oh
you did in south africa yeah with great
whites okay so let me
so okay hold on
now because i remember this story hold
on i could have put a restaurant gotten
in the cage and i decided
that my nephews and my brother-in-law
should go first they went yeah so you
didn't actually get in the water now
hold on no did you get in the water
i probably didn't get in the water if i
think back on it i didn't get in the
water but here did they see any great
whites so no so
hold on
just jump
now what happened was there are black
tip sharks there were two killer whales
that were spotted in the bay
of that area you guys spotted them the
two the two killer whales they they
killed four great whites they ate their
lips
and all the carrot whites were like
we'll see you later
this is not where we hang out with the
fishermen and they left yep so we did
see some bronze whalers and their sharks
we saw some bronze whales and they look
like great whites
so did we see grey whites was in the
water i don't remember exactly
diving and you've never done it well i
don't know i don't remember exactly
never done it and you're [ __ ] on
there's a bronze whaler right there dude
we saw those things they're stupid look
at their stupid eyes they're dangerous
oh damn yeah if it ain't great white i'm
not that interested let's be honest
you know what bull or tiger tiger i'd be
in the bull of tiger no one does tiger
shark diving i said i said we were
seeing these swells i go do people surf
here and the woman goes
you know when they say there are no
sharks in this area
they're up that way and you're in an
area where all the most dangerous sharks
are right here all the time
so no nobody surfaced in this area
nobody i was like okay
giant sharks giant great whites
let me see a target tiger shark the
water's so beautiful and so blue you
just want to jump in it it's like this
is where all the sharks are like right
and and you see the shore and you're
like it's an abandoned store you just
swim right off
there and that's that's a tiger shark
yeah they're they're the most everywhere
the most aggressive bull sharks tiger
sharks sharks the worst so most of the
attacks in hawaii tiger tiger sharks oh
really they're so [ __ ] brutal yeah
look at that [ __ ] just chilling
with locomotives they're huge and
they're finding their bellies like
they'll eat anything yeah oh they
[ __ ]
tires and [ __ ] they're not hearing a
peep out of you why is that one red that
has to be fake right that's fake that
red one that's fake that would be lit as
[ __ ] yeah god that'd be sick though
what's the bull shark look
they look sharks are not [ __ ] around
they look like tigers but fatter than
bull sharks and go in fresh water yeah
they'll jump in rivers with fresh water
and they're like more testosterone
higher testosterone look at that
[ __ ] yeah bull shark is no joke
is that a bull shark no that's a
[ __ ] right there
wow well she's not scared of that thing
yeah that thing will take your
your well take both your legs off yeah
bull and tiger so aggressive yeah and
killer worlds are [ __ ] them up yo yeah
look at that thing eating a [ __ ]
turtle
oh yeah they eat turtles so tiger shirts
imagine me that's why you don't want to
swim between quiet and this other thing
because
they're
wow dude when i when i went to hawaii me
and my girl went scuba diving and there
was a sea turtle i'm like oh turtles are
slow i'm gonna catch that thing holy
[ __ ] they're faster than the water oh
yeah i mean dude that's there i mean he
said i'm gonna catch this yeah i'm gonna
hang on to him like [ __ ] moan or
something
dude yeah like see you later oh i was
like i was in slow motion i'm gonna turn
this up now let's turn this up
yeah
yeah dude he was i mean when i say i
didn't have a someone's like have you
catch a turtle you get 20 million
dollars i couldn't do it no oh really
because they go like this they go you
got me tails
oh you got me turned up
jim what are you doing this weekend
[ __ ]
doing some [ __ ] i'm gonna try to just
heal
up i'll tell you
when's your next concert the 18th 18th
yeah actually how's coming with us now
where's it at
uh a place called rebel lounge
in phoenix yeah oh yeah seeing a lot of
great shows out there really yeah like
what uh the casualties beach slang um
okay mm-hmm yeah i got footage of me all
right
in the pit is it close to jt
no can you stop by somebody uh
oh it's on indian school and jt's is on
indian school jt send me wings yeah
summer worms
oh you i'll give you the list for uh
buffalo wings in uh buffalo okay
don't go the original place sucks
brother
mother mother is a great mother is great
chin bring out best uh buffalo wings and
buffalo
there's one place where there's wings
you know
just best wings in buffalo there's wings
though
it's stupid you know what i mean
dude
buffalo's they originated there i know
but it's just chicken wings oh don't
buffalo it's just a chicken yeah eight
at 12 spots
no there's one that's gold's or
something with the skin yeah [ __ ] you
elmo's yeah [ __ ] you elmo's is good
are you a flat or a drum guy gabriel's
kate elmo's her mama uh my mosers that's
where you want to go mama's gabriel's
gate's great as well okay i'll go to my
mosers there's one the original the
place where the wing was invented which
is weird they own that where it was
invented by some old lady not great
wings no nope but that's moses what is
that no moser's is different there we go
moses
tavern me and jay ate their every day
really
oh those look good okay mr t
um i'll go to mother mother's good huh
mother
hey how did you know that i signed that
song you did yeah goddamn did well oh
really you know i'm saying dancing
awesome where was i yeah we were all
goddamn uh
[Music]
yeah oh no
i'll turn it up
i would imagine so this song
that's been sing a song and i said to
myself you know
i got i got a lot of songs in my head
but i'm not a singer did you how old are
you
i thought to myself well dude 2015 buddy
seven years ago
damn
[Applause]
[Applause]
you're more ripped now brian
you are he's more ripped
[Music]
god just do the song
the crowd's like
he's talking i know i want to hear him
shave your head brian sing like a bird
god [ __ ] your hair looks like the
corn mazes
[Music]
this is hilarious
there you
[Music]
children not go walk my way
okay brian
why chico's hearted
god pull your belt up
right
right
[Music]
hey you're dead serious
i'm trying to focus cause i couldn't get
my voice like that
look at his legs look at his legs just
choppin
you already you already knew this song
before i had to rehearse it there oh you
were oh god he got it yeah
somebody's like that's a hard song
saying you're not saying oh it's not a
karaoke thing no you got it that's
simple yeah
the whole [ __ ] thing is on there
what a [ __ ]
weird time
dude that's freaking good right i know
that's just something like
i'm super impressed people a lot like me
and i think glenn danzig would be very
proud
i think i did better
look at that bag
stupid dude
i love that they have the violinist up
there
if you wanna find him with me there you
go brian
did
[Music]
i think i walk off
yeah you do
what the [ __ ]
was it awesome with this one
oh this was awesome yeah this is that
move tower
we did sets before then
you're like iggy pop
yeah except for not as muscular
no he's just shredded he's not much i
think you tossed the mic here and walked
away
that was a great performance i really
enjoyed that
yeah
don't you toss the mic and walk off i
did let the first time i ever did it i
[ __ ] tossed it and just walked up oh
they had to help me up they're going to
help me out
that was good held me up and like helped
me off oh hey let me see that 11 year
old with foo fighters right here this
one this is new
oh she's she's amazing this 11 year
old's like a prodigy her name is nandy
yeah i met her oh really yeah yeah she's
amazing incredible have her on your
podcast
huh have around your pocket i live in
london
watch your in this [ __ ] drum track to
this song is not even playing the drums
right yeah watch her kill this she's 11.
yes
she's amazing
oh wow
you got to go to her instagram after
this chen yeah i don't know if we could
play this one on the show but watch her
kill that like
watch her get it
damn bro that's all her
uh yeah go to her
for instagram [ __ ] at 11. rocking with
the foo fighters
some kids
n-a-n they like from they haven't
yeah they're a different um i don't know
like what was that uh so
dude she came out to california jammed
with tom morello chad smith uh the
drummer of incubus like she like she's
amazing look at her
this is red hot chili peppers
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
she was on my boy toby's podcast and
stuff she's she's amazing
[Music]
now does she start i know yeah
[Music]
so when i the coolest thing so when i
met her her and her family the coolest
thing would you meet him
see on the far left in the purple chin
where she's yelling yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
when i met her and her family they they
let her be a kid like she was she did my
uh homies podcast she's gonna play the
[ __ ] drums but i hear you yeah but
like they just let her be like she's
like she was excited to walk the dog
yeah like just stuff like that like just
things that kids love that's what was
like
really
cool 11 and just kicking ass yeah still
kids yeah she jamming with my boy matt
helders from arctic monkeys yes i
remember she went viral because even
when she was younger she was rocking out
yeah
i think her first the first video she
did was her nirvana uh cover
she did in bloom and she was like
screaming and everyone's just like who
is she yeah wow
oh man so after she did that performance
with the foo fighter she has a little
brother i think he's eight and he was
just like bawling with excitement for
yeah they were like walking backstage it
was it's the cutest thing man blowing up
man yeah
let me see
great people
that's her brother yeah
[Music]
[Music]
how old is he he i think he that's what
that was at the time thomas is six and
i'm nine yeah wow but they're eleven and
eight now
holy [ __ ] that's gonna happen more and
more now because of youtube i think
youtube was one of the biggest reasons
why [ __ ] yeah but yeah she's amazing
though
that's nice all right kids hi kids i'm
in san jose thursday friday saturday
chappelle lacey david lucas myself is in
san jose california san jose improv one
show thursday two shows friday two shows
saturday and then september 24th
september 25th san antonio texas bud
light event center one show friday one
show saturday denver colorado september
30th through october 2nd las vegas
nevada october 7th through october 9th
brea october 15th through 17th the thick
boy collab with built church drops this
friday morning friday morning the thick
boys shirts will be available at
thickboy.com
buffalo new york this weekend tomorrow
thursday friday saturday i got denver
colorado
on the 25th of september 24th 25th 23rd
24th 25th chicago illinois improv
schomburg improv september 30
october 1 october 2
columbus ohio funny bone october eight
and nine come see me
boom october seven through the night
tampa florida side splitters uh florida
florida's still been popping huh they
just they just wide the [ __ ] open
they've been at the way the whole time
huh
florida florida be popping like that but
yeah october 7th through the night tampa
florida i'm ready to kick ass out there
i actually like tampa a lot
but miami is probably my favorite city
all right
big booties love you guys
[Applause]